c'est extrêmement frustrant et personne
ne peut jamais rien faire rentrer
d'urgence au pays en mars dernier
alexandre vigneault la côte et tente
depuis sept mois de se faire rembourser
pour ses billets de vols annulés
transat nous oblige à passer par la
compagnie de la carte de crédit qui elle
a sa propre police d'assurance
d'annulation de voyage et ils se
renvoient continuellement la balle
quelque chose de très grave dans la
mesure où c'est comme si les passagers
les citoyens devaient financer les
compagnies aériennes une saga à laquelle
le gouvernement compte finalement
s'attaquer idée des compagnies aériennes
d'offrir des coupons et non pas des
remboursements a été très très mal
digéré par des centaines de mille
canadiens ottawa envisage de négocier
une aide pour les transporteurs aériens
durement touché par la pandémie mais pas
sans conditions le remboursement des
voyageurs doit faire partie des
discussions
il n'y a pas de question évidemment de
signer un chèque en blanc à penser en
bannière yens là je dirais enfin il
était temps jeu sachant que le canada
c'est pratiquement le seul pays qui
n'est pas intervenue pour supporter les
compagnies aériennes pour ce spécialiste
c'est une bonne nouvelle que le
gouvernement se portent à la rescousse
de l'industrie mais il faudra trouver un
équilibre
sita totalité va au remboursement des
billets au fond bon on fera des heureux
avec les passagers il faut le faire
abandonner mais si on ne règle pas le
problème de fond parce que chaque mois
les pertes du secteur au pays se
comptent par centaines des millions de
dollars il faut que tout ça ça fasse
partie de cette espèce d'entente mais
encore là c'est pas sorcier c'est pas
compliqué c'est il faut juste s'asseoir
et discuter dans un esprit d'ouverture
comme les américains comme les européens
trop peu trop tard pour certains
voyageurs que mélanie l'emprunt au
niveau de la rétrofacturation
joël et où les délais légal sont
dépensés locke donc la non prise de
position du ministre quand sortent de la
plupart des voyageurs présentement son
qu'on essaie avec lors qu'ils voyagent
coincé et désigner ce que j'attends
sincèrement bridge où j'ai aucune
attente je continue à me battre par
principe
issigeac audrey charbonneau radio canada
mon frère